Works uh here I put product and quotes
all right let's go let's go hello
welcome everybody
we gotta
mad tasty here
if anyone ever if any drink companies
ever want to sponsor comma you know we'd
uh we'd love to have you
um
preferably something a bit light on the
sugar you know
uh
uh Link Works you like you link to my
background this is this is my poster in
my office
um so let's give everyone a minute to
get in here my board just says tiny grad
a comma
uh
it's my large monitor I set up plant
automation today look at this automation
love automation guys
guys
um what do we have to show you
oh is there any secrets on the I don't
know if I can show you we have like
fancy new metrics boards but I don't
think I can show them to you
um
yeah
it's that thing what what is that
what is that
I'm zooming in what is it it's moving
are those are those cat ears
[Laughter]
wait it might even talk
oh yeah look it's making its way over
here wow let's see if it's a friend
hello friend
can can you oh you you hit down there
can you talk
you can just blink your eyes
oh that's cool
can you hear me
oh oh oh oh all right all right all
right all right all right
um yeah I mean you know it's it's a will
it fall no way it's got wheels
um
um yes so uh you know
there'll be some cool announcements at
Comic-Con
at Comic-Con you can you can come over
here you can come on in here it's good
um there'll be some cool announcements
at Comic-Con related to The Comma body
uh look guys is it come here come here
it's using machine learning technology
for this and by Machine learning
technology I mean it's remote control in
the same way the cruise cars are uh
I mean I I wish you could you could talk
and the talking worked
oh
okay it said something it's like Pikachu
it just says Pikachu
okay all right well you know he's just
gonna Kenny's just gonna kiss his Kenny
or Bob or Billy I don't know
okay okay I hear you
um
George You Banned Me on Twitch but you
can't ban me everywhere bro
I just banned you easy okay
uh so so so
we are uh yeah no we banned him it's all
good uh you know some people that's
their moment of Fame okay so we're here
for a product announcement we're here
for a product announcement uh does does
uh does our friends here know what the
product announcement is I don't think he
does
okay okay I hear you I hear you
um
is that a comma one on the body no this
is a comma three oh oh you like it
because it's green no it just has a
green uh
green side
um
we have a product announcement today and
there's 213 people here that's a good
number of people uh there's Secrets
everywhere so I can't you know there's
so many secrets for Comic-Con uh if
you're not coming by the way Comic-Con
guys let's see uh this is in secret this
is just tiny grad
um
let's let's look at the webpage for
Comic-Con let's go through Comic-Con
here
want to understand the true future of
self-driving cars and Robotics
okay you can you can you can go home
and you can chill if you want but you
can also go home
oh he's listening oh that's great I
think he can hear us bye
bye bye bye body oh he's a little drunk
that's that's you know it's a holiday
um
uh I want to understand the true future
of self-driving cars and Robotics come
to Comic-Con an IRL event full of
technical talks from our people uh
deeb's gonna talk uh Dave's ahead of
openpile Ed Harold's gonna talk he's our
CTO uh
wait Shing is going to talk uh he works
on driver monitoring uh and then we got
burgers for lunch uh roby's gonna talk
he works on our Hardware Greg's going to
talk he runs our infrastructure your
scene's gonna talk works on our ml uh
training and I'm gonna talk
uh and then we have uh Jason from
Discord who's going to talk happy hour
in The Comedy Awards flatbreads and
tendys I heard we got demos and they
were delicious and then um some up close
demos so uh you can get tickets right
here uh there's only 23 early saver
tickets remaining and then you'll be
stuck with a general admission ticket so
I recommend buying your tickets uh right
now uh will it be recorded probably but
do not miss it come in real life because
things happen in real life not on the
internet the internet is all fake
um also VIP we've sold three VIP tickets
so far
um I think you'll be very happy if you
buy a VIP ticket uh we have a candle at
dinner there's going to be candles
um
it's it's gonna be good
uh it's just like the cruise cars the
bodies just like the cruise cars it's
autonomous if you consider that
autonomous
um VIP also it's in San Diego uh this
was some pictures from Comic-Con last
year it's at the same place
uh so it's uh gonna be uh fun uh the
product is not just a shell the product
is not just a Shale to get you in here
um but I don't know if the product's
ready yet let me uh head over to open
pilot and see if the product is ready
how's our product coming
we we are there secrets everywhere
oh there's Secrets okay okay what
okay you're merging our product now all
right great
uh where are the secrets
oh yeah that's far away they can't see
anything on this desk you're gonna get
some like zoomed in blurry picture and
they're gonna be like damn we figured it
out
comma selling puppies
um
wish it worked on early C3 no it doesn't
work on early c3s it only works on c3s
that have come out in the last year
um so so 261 we're still growing we
can't do the product announcement yet we
got to build up the hype you know after
this commercial break
okay the commercial's over but don't
worry we're still not going to tell you
who gets eliminated from the island
because otherwise how would we fill a 42
minute TV spot with this reality show uh
okay we have like metrics over there
they're too blurry for you to see
um should we visit Alex let's visit Alex
uh
uh well we can't visit Alex because
there's no Alex we're gonna go
downstairs
I know you're excited about the product
announcement but it's not time yet it's
not time yet we'll give it we'll give it
a few more minutes let's go take a look
at downstairs let's go to our Factory
uh by the way if you want to come work
here
uh this is a very chill place to work uh
you can come work here and like we're
gonna we're gonna win guys uh you know
and I've been saying this for a long
time it turns out winning just takes a
long ass time but like you've seen
everyone with the driving simulators
like commoditize your compliment love it
there's going to be simulators we got a
network we're ready to go
uh let's go in over here
um work sounds bad well if works not for
you then this is not for you but if
you'd like to work
it's a very chill place to work out
and just swipe into this door here
let's go
you don't have any secrets right
these are normal comma threes right no
secrets
I'll check out these are the common
threes before they get made
these I think these boards are half
populated or they're just empty
just empty boards but they go in here oh
look it's an Alex
and then this is a jet printer
this machine is a pick and place machine
puts all the parts on the board we're
fixing up some old boards here
uh this is our Reflow oven
hey Alex
we're live
what do you mean you got news for me
oh oh it's live oh
oh no I didn't tell anyone what it was
that's what they don't know
oh no
well good the website takes a while to
push anyway
um great uh yeah this is our inspection
we inspect all the commentary boards
like a super precise cameras okay I
gotta go we gotta go do the announcement
I mean maybe this is the right place to
do it yeah
right here in the middle of the
production floor
we have some comma threes here on the
stress test all right we're doing it
we're doing it we're doing it
today the comma three comma care
extended warranty goes live you guys
have been asking for it for years for
years
and today we are finally at a place at a
company where we can actually do it and
I'll tell you guys this is going to
print money
uh this is going to print money you know
because the failure rate is low but if
you want warranty if you want that peace
of mind you should buy it at 400 and it
just extends your factory warranty to
two years instead of one
uh so yeah that's the product uh is the
website really live do you want to like
bring it up on your phone and we'll
stream from your phone
oh we have a computer in here
over here
oh we use this to buy things off Amazon
I see
oh okay just go to the go to the website
I think so
oh good website oh wow you can buy a
comma three and when you buy a common
three wait wait wait where is it a body
all those oh comma care whoa the comma
care extended warranty now you can buy
this either with a new comma three or
with a comma three up to one year if you
do not have a common device you can buy
the extended warranty but it's a
donation
um we do love donating purchase an
additional year of warranty coverage and
then you can read a bunch of fine print
Alex would you like to read some fine
print to the people yes
[Music]
how to apply to bulk discount orders and
if you made an international purchase
and you have a warranty
um it's not apply to Common twos so
please don't ask and uh it's just like
our limited Hardware uh warranty against
defects it does not apply to Accidental
damage so if you drop your device break
your screen wait I'm literally we're
literally getting booed right now
they're booing what this has got to be a
prank what do you mean don't buy it if
you don't like it
you know you just can't make people
happy man it doesn't the warranty
doesn't affect you if you don't buy it
wait maybe it's just one guy booing
just ordered a Tesla after watching this
[Laughter]
you look guys uh
calling a warranty a product oh they
wanted a product Oh guys you're gonna
have to come to Comic-Con for that oh oh
you wanted a product announcement that's
why product was in quotes whenever it's
in quotes it's never what you want today
you learned about quotes
[Laughter]
I'm literally crying right now look you
don't have to buy it that's the price
right if you want to sell 100 200
warranties you're welcome to but we sell
them for 400 and we make a ton of
money on them but to be fair people are
always asking about this they're like
what if I break my advice out of
warranty guess what uh three two year
warranty is cheaper than a comma three
was last year
for 1900 you can get the comma three and
the warranty for less than a comma three
cost last year
do it for three years it's two
um
should raise the common three prize and
include harness we could think about
that the parts availability is amazing
thank you thank you thank you we're
getting rid of it now that we sell
extended warranties no just kidding uh
look we support the products the comma
two failed the comma two was not our
best product
uh you know we were
it's hard to run a profitable company
it's hard to run a company when you
actually try to make money and don't
just want to do scams
um
but no it's okay I mean it was decent it
was cool for what it was but we didn't
have the maturity that the comma 3 has
we now have a big fancy Factory
making all these things
um
companies failing
it's news to me bro
uh
behind this door we have profitability
uh is this a no fault warranty no if you
break if you like break the screen I'm
not going to give you a new screen but
if it breaks in normal usage we'll fix
it
uh how are sales sales are way up uh
since uh we lowered the price
sales have doubled since we dropped the
price to 14.99
uh so they don't they went up so much
that we actually want to back order for
the comma three
um
if you think 400 is too much I don't
think it's that far off from Apple
uh
uh you know it's it's an option
people are always asking we're giving
you an option
lovely option for the peace of mind
thank you thank you for the positivity
good sir
um how much is a steam deck I don't know
I don't sell steam decks
all right let's uh oh yes and if you're
just joined uh Comic-Con
Comic-Con is our yearly conference by
yearly
um
what typically kills a comma
does it count if the body falls no but
we have something to address that and
you'll have to come to Comic-Con for
that
um no Icom has been
comfortably profitable for the year uh
we got the sales boost we needed what
we're focusing on now in that factory
um we're doing a lot of stuff to like
okay so like our Counting
historically was just uh
was just like asset based accounting we
weren't tracking cogs correctly uh so we
didn't exactly know how much a given
comma 3 cost to make we had a ballpark
idea but um we're working on just
improving this a ton uh We've made some
parts changes to the comma three
completely seamless to you screen has
changed the cameras have changed
uh and we figured out how to get
they're they're both cheaper and better
they're like literally if if you if you
buy things in bulk and you plan things
you can get things that are both cheaper
and better and this is how you build
incredible consumer electronics
uh do I expect additional price drops no
right now we're working on it's not
about dropping the price it's about
increasing our margins all right so I
did I took a hit to margins when I when
I uh when I lowered the price
um you know I'd like to get our margins
back to 60 and they're not 60 right now
um
how much do we pay software engineers at
comma uh
uh again if you're looking like well I'm
gonna maximize my TCO yeah going to Fang
and do nothing with your life uh but if
you want a comfortable salary uh I think
we pay between 80 and 150 uh and then
you can choose equity and how much
Equity you choose depends on how uh the
salary
uh how much Equity you choose depends on
how much salary you get if you want more
Equity you get less salary if you want
more salary you get uh less equity
uh I mean look
we had an employee buy a house off his
comma stock there's money in it
um
any remote opportunities we don't have
opportunities periodly uh period I I
hate that uh word what the hell's an
opportunity you want to work remotely
contribute to GitHub right uh you want a
job remotely well I'll think about it
after you contribute to GitHub for a
while
um and the tiny Corps remote uh my other
company the tiny Corps is all remote uh
but again the bar is even higher to get
hired so
heavy device falls off the glass and I
have to glue it back constantly buy a
mount follow the instructions and I
promise you won't have to do that make
sure you clean the windshield good and
make sure you leave it up there to dry
for like 24 to 48 hours and you'll never
have to stick it on again
why doesn't comma register some
Representatives yeah
someday we'll have to do this
uh someday we'll have to do this we'll
have like like qualified installers and
you'll go through like a hey you know
what I really I'd like someone else to
manage this and take the profit from it
um but we'll set it up if we have to
uh it can verify you're paying attention
if you're wearing sunglasses
again a lot of the DM Now isn't to end
it's just like looking at you like if a
human in the deceit next to you can tell
whether you're paying attention the
comma three can tell
um you have side cameras the comma 3 is
a 360 cam
great work on the new Cabana that's all
Dean Lee I believe I think Dean Lee and
uh and Willem are a bet
um
what about an Upstate on the comma 3
lifespan I mean lifespan of devices is
however well you take care of it and
stuff you know
they don't like they don't have an
expiry day it's not like eggs bro love
the new product thank you thank you I
love the positivity
um so let's figure out how many we sold
let's see if we can get that
uh can we can we get out how many we
sold if someone at comma is watching
this and wants to post it on uh on Slack
uh
was the DM model trained on hand labeled
data yes some of it
uh it's boosted we have some we did some
hand labeling and we did some automatic
classification it's it's a combination
uh does it work with Chinese EVS I'm not
sure I don't know any that do uh the 3D
print for your ODB Port disconnected
I don't think so what you mean your
comma power the 3D printer I don't think
so
um
didn't I leave the company I'm the
president of the company I don't work
here every day
um
I do uh no I mean the company's mostly
independent now I mean you know Alex and
Harold uh run the day-to-day
adiba in the company
um
what happened to marketing intern well
my deal with comma about being a
marketing intern and someone said you
know I thought about this a little bit
it's like we've never had a thousand
common threes in stock once we have a
thousand comment threes in stock the
marketing intern will return and I got
some sick marketing ideas
um
it did disconnect
what do you mean
like post a post a picture on Discord
and we'll take a look uh when are we
where are we on navigate on open pilot
come to Comic-Con come to Comic-Con and
you will hear all about navigating open
pilot
uh
uh can you develop a magnetic easily
removable amount why do you want to
remove the device leave it on your
windshield
how does he affect the comma 3 should be
fine
uh I mean sometimes
uh sometimes
you uh
okay stop spamming chat if you spam chat
band
um can I sell you a digital pass the com
con you think I'm gonna sell little
passes you think I'm an IP scammer bro
um what will give you the VIP digital
experience come on come on you think I
do that it's gonna be streamed probably
I don't know we'll see if I want to pay
the streamers
um where might you find more information
on the design role do you really want it
if you really want it you don't have to
ask me that question you'll find plenty
of information
where do you really find more
information you you want to get hired
for design it comma go contribute to
open pilot go contribute designs to open
pilot get people to start using them in
Discord and I'm like damn that's who we
want to hire you know what I mean
um literally go you know what's terrible
our lane change UI go commit a better
Lane change UI to to open pilot and show
that you have design skills by doing
that I mean even if you know you should
be able to code two everyone should be
able to code but
um
what the heat the Contour should be fine
I mean sometimes it overheats and it'll
tell you that it overheats uh pretty
rarely but yeah if you leave it out in a
baking sun it's going to take a little
bit to cool down
um but it's not gonna break the device
no it's not like Elon saying I'll pay
you if I like your system
that's that's doing six months of work
I'm asking you to do a week of work and
if you're not willing to do a week of
work to get a job you're going to have
for five years I I don't know how to
help you man
um
how does the latest build compare with
FSD we're focused on different things
from FSD but like we're getting there
we're we're working on the same uh you
know sort of stuff navigate an open
pilot is going to uh
again all right all right that's a
different approach it's end to end it
approaches it from a different angle but
when navigate on open pilot launches
I'll come to Comic-Con
uh you will uh
be able to type in a destination and the
car will go there watch the Taco Bell
video if you didn't
I love the navigation that's already
available in master awesome uh I don't
think navigated homepod I think you
might have to enable some Flags I'm not
really sure what it is any plans for
outside of U.S
are you from India I always get this
question from India like it just works
man I mean I've seen some of the Indian
roads and no it doesn't work there
nothing works there
um
what are you hiding behind that mirror
what is that like the Arsenal's punch
line and
it's not a mirror it's a whiteboard
uh any plans to remove the can FD
Hardware
uh you know either you gotta talk to the
hardware team for road maps I'm the
president I don't do road maps
um
works like a charm in Norway awesome
uh
uh encrypted can buses by votes like I
said once Maine oh I drove around cones
oh look and we didn't even need to
detect the cones look at that
um
oh should you wait for the next release
I mean what next release
I don't know what to tell you like what
do you think that the comma 4 is going
to have that the comma 3 doesn't right
like for the comma two everyone was like
man oh yeah no it needs more cameras it
needs more cameras and then like we ship
the comma three and it has more cameras
well I don't know what else you're
waiting for
all right navigate an open pot managed
to turn that's good
uh can I talk a little bit more about
the longitudinal strategy of cars so 60
uh 33 of cars use open pilot
longitudinal 33 use stock and 33 use
stock but have open pilot longitudinal
available that's 66 that's pretty good
for me
don't chase long tails
uh buy a car that's supported
constant followers and profiles yeah
didn't you see did you see the toggle
there's there's a toggle now you can set
aggressive normal and chill uh and it'll
determine how closely it follows and a
whole bunch of other kind of
aggressiveness Maneuvers because in
general people who follow clothes also
want aggressive driving in other places
quick acceleration
uh slowing down less returns all that
kind of stuff
the comma 3 comes jailbroken that's true
that's true the common three is a dev
kit you know I had someone ask me about
that about the dev kit thing people are
like comma doesn't sell a real product
they only sell a dev kit what do you
think a dev kit is bro it's a word if
the word Dev kid bothers you it's not
for you
but
if you're not bothered by words and can
see what things actually are what's the
difference
uh uh
thank you
select profiles on a button some force
will do that I'm sure if something's
really good we'll merge it
let's look at the warranty
wait how do I buy it
was the buy button
oh this is like a oh I'm in some like
weird website thing
here we go
extended warranty
um everything works oh experimental
works much better on freeway it's
awesome
um if you park it in the sun where it's
really hot it may take a few minutes to
cool down before you can engage but it
won't break the device
um
right because like the device is rated
to handle really like 85c but kind of up
to 105 for some components and you're
not going to get hotter than 85 just
sitting on your windshield you can get
up to like I've seen 80. uh but once it
turns on it might go over that so it's
not going to let you engage but it you
know it keeps it locked until it cools
down but again this is only the most
extreme uh weather conditions don't sell
out what do you think I'm going to sell
out
what do you think the world could
possibly offer a man
uh you know we're going to sell
self-driving cars and it turns out
everything just takes a really long time
I think it's gonna take seven more years
uh I think I think by the end of the
decade
the common devices will be able to
you'll be able to put in a destination
and
um
let's say 99 of the time it gets you
there
um
um well yeah right and that's the other
thing too like having open source
software kind of makes you structurally
impossible of certain kinds of selling
out always be afraid when you're using a
thing like even if the people are nice
now if you're using closer software or
you're using God forbid some web thing
you know watch out for like things like
GitHub you know
um they might be nice now but they can
flip a switch
for charity sure why not
we love charity but only like a Good
Charity like like a charity that's gonna
like make Power cheap
boxing for cheap power I love it uh do
we need more dcam images more decam
images are great I'm not sure the last
time we tried to train a segment but you
know more is always better
and we are going to train and ship that
model
uh
in a bit so I want to do a complete car
no I don't want to make a car why do I
want to make a car
don't make you free make it cheap it's
much better
um
F-150 Upstream to master I think it's
gonna happen
think there's really blockers on that
how annoying is the install on that car
punches for power yeah I love it cheap
power let's figure out how to make Power
cheap for everybody Cheap's good free is
dangerous
on freemium someone subsidizing you
would I fight zoc Zuck looks Jack now I
don't know
uh yeah yeah yeah so the only thing the
comma 3 lacks is compute but that's why
we put the expansion port on there it's
going to be hard for us to keep up like
you can't buy Nvidia chips so just buy a
cheap gaming laptop shove it under the
seat and connect wire
um
I think Zuck could be my ass to be
honest
uh
I mean now Zach not old Zuck I'd have to
I'd have to practice fighting too
um
no I wouldn't fight death I don't know
anything about Destiny man
uh let's always bring that one up I
don't know he's a YouTuber
uh
does that include EU roads oh because
they're so different it includes
everywhere except India roads okay
because I've seen India Rhodes now
and
I don't know maybe it'll even work there
I don't know might work everywhere
I think that matters though you think
like that's the limiting factor oh does
it work in the rain so stupid it's all
about intelligence right you build
intelligent things and they'll work
anywhere that a human does
can you drive on EU roads if you're an
EU person can you drive on U.S roads
right so why is there a difference stop
discriminating between silicon life and
biological life
um
wait what
the VIP tickets sold out
wait no no that didn't just happen
wait oh my God
wait this is actually selling tons of
tickets
why did you guys buy general admission
tickets and not really save your tickets
but I don't know what to tell you yo
no the early bird sold out but the early
saver didn't
I don't know 12 people can't read and
bought general admission tickets instead
of early saver tickets but I don't know
what to say
uh
wow
the candlelit dinner got you guys all
right all right I mean we can't do more
it's VIP I don't want more than 15
people if those are legit then you got
the 15 VIPs man you should have watched
this stream
uh
uh right
um yeah we'll include like maybe we'll
include like five more shots for five
more spots for the Mega benefactor VIP
and it'll be like 10 racks
um
you guys are making Comic-Con profitable
you know I love to make things
profitable
all right uh do we have anything else
you like my five lighthouses that the
other body the thing on the top of the
body was that was a Vibe tracker used
for calibrating our slam system
C3 works better in the rain than you can
see the C3 never works better than you
but it's not because the cameras can't
see I actually believe the cameras can
see better than you can in the rain I do
not believe that it's anywhere near as
intelligent as you are even if you're
rather dimwitted the comma three is even
more dilated
um what do I do all day
well I have I'm the president of comma
and I founded a new company called the
tiny Corp and I worked there
um you can watch my GitHub you can just
like I do all my work in public you can
go on my GitHub and watch all my
comments that's where I do all that I
code
um cameras can see better you can see in
the rain part of the reason for that is
the camera is right up close to the
windshield so when you have raindrops
hit the windshield like you need like a
wiper to clear them away but if it's
close it's just like it's out of the
depth of field so you can just see
through it
um another nice thing about the common
three is it has two eyes so like if you
happen to get a raindrop in a bad place
the other camera can see and that
already all works is putting both into
the model
what are you using for slam we built it
why should you buy the Box this is not
here we're here to talk about Gamma
um
where do you think we're gonna run the
comma model you're gonna have to put a
tiny box in the back of your car and
then connect that to your commentary
give it some super powers
uh display simulator anime simulator
stuff planned maybe maybe Harold wants
to do a uh a stream next week and show
it off
on ban you what oh now you're getting
double band bro
um what is slam simultaneous
localization mapping it's the asking the
question uh what's the map look like and
where am I
um supercharged comma 3.
sweet uh uh next week sounds good
uh yeah just like drive around the
simulator just like driving
forever.jpg.jif.mpg.getex
play it and Win It
um can you download the weights of a
slam model it's just it's the same model
super combo with slam
I mean not exactly but
it's yeah
I'm he hears I don't make train I don't
think training should be open source
um but I do think wage should be open
source weights for local inference
should be open source and uh
uh obviously the runner should be open
source and that's like what album pilot
is I mean that's like my view on open
source machine learning I think like
llama and llama even llama could have
actually made the way it's available for
download we make our way to available
for download in open pilot uh we have
since the beginning
so yeah the weights are free to download
the architectures are open but the
training stack is closed uh because
again the training stack doesn't benefit
individuals the training stack benefits
large corporations there's only a few
people who can run that training stack
are our our uh supercomputer now costs
over a million dollars uh and you just
need a million dollar computer in order
to train this stuff so
um Acura MDX I don't know why that one's
not supported
show your server room now we're not
going to serve a room today
uh uh I have the open pilot lost
landscape as picture to the right oh
that thing yeah uh no no here uh you
know what I I saw a cool thing I can
show it off with waiting uh was working
on this
we're working on confidence
um that show you how confident the uh
the open pilot is in this area so these
are places where the confidence is red
uh these are places where we you know
engaging probably won't really work and
look you see parking lots uh parking
lots driveways right like it's not
really going to work there
um
what
oh man
wait this is not loading
oh we have to like download yeah
uh uh these are all videos
it'll be cool when it loads but yeah
then we have yellow ones down here and
you see those are
uh hang on let me let me fix this
uh bad Chrome
bad
so much okay so much memory in this
computer all right there we go
what
it's just broken
like I just wanna try Firefox maybe
Firefox works do I have Firefox
Firefox
oh Firefox box all right cool
uh yeah Chrome wow comes the problem so
these are red confidence uh places where
engaging probably won't really work you
see like there's like a left lane and a
pass and where you're hanging on the
lane line
um can I send a link to buy the warranty
uh you can find it just go to common.ai
so then we can look here these are
yellow areas so yeah these are places
where it's going to kind of work
you know tight traffic
[Music]
roads neighborhood and then we have
green areas and these are places where
uh
it's totally just gonna work
you can look and they're just mostly
boring highways
um is it easier to hire a guy in India
to drive the car remotely you have two
problems latency and incentives
um
is there some calibration of the
confidence yeah so it has to do with its
expected number of disengagements per
minute
uh so you see here
uh this is transitions from green to
Yellow this is expected to have
you know one disengagement about every
um
well that many minutes
that unit's not great uh but yeah there
we go so green is over 10 minutes
yellow is over one minute and red is
less than one minute you're gonna have
to disengage in
uh so we're gonna ship that that's gonna
be like cool we need a designer we're
hiring a designer uh if you want to come
work your own design the best way to get
that job is to fix something up in
GitHub look I'm not asking you to do six
months of work I'm asking to do a couple
days of work and if you're not willing
to do a couple days of work for a major
life change in your life like a new job
like I don't know what to tell you bro
um but yeah fix up something show that
you can do it even just if you just put
some beautiful mocks like if you're like
you know I can't really code that well
and open pile it's confusing I don't
know the hardware to run it put some
beautiful mocks and GitHub issues yeah
um additional discount for C3 extended
warranties who paid full price no
come on come on come on what are you
what are you hassling me for come on I
try my best look guys like using comma
we make money now but not like tons
of money
so much you know so much money I've made
off this company
I haven't sold a single share
um and I've paid myself my average
salary has been like
under six figures certainly
um so you know I've paid not much money
but you know it's not about now it's
about the future right like it's it's
about you know eventually this thing's
gonna print money
um
exponential growth
hockey stick guys hockey stick
uh no it's not 78 000 anymore I'm
actually getting no salary right now
because I really only come in like one
day a week and it's probably just for
talking
um
so I don't get a salary right now
uh also I have another company which
also doesn't pay me a salary
um that company will pay me a salary
sooner though because we're gonna start
to make money
uh
uh is the square painting a secret
message yes can you decode it it's
steganography try the LSB and XR with
the Bible
um
what else we got
uh one time actually Cynthia
uh yeah at least this is cool we're
trying with them any corporate
Partnerships in the near future
How's that gonna happen
I mean maybe I don't know who bought 15
starring this stream maybe like the
whole GM executive team is going to be
there and then you know we'll see
um
wow I can't believe the VIP tickets sold
out like who bought them
that's just crazy
and what about all the VIPs who are just
hearing about it now you just don't wow
oh maybe there was I don't know what
happened
whatever
it looks like there might be VIP tickets
back
okay it's only six were sold I don't
really understand or maybe we just added
more I don't know what happened but
there's a few VIP tickets left but it
seems like we sold a lot
oh if someone has them in the car oh
that's interesting
uh interesting
there's a comma 3 void manufacturer
warranties
there was plenty of stuff to Google
about that uh uh your warranty is
between you and your manufacturer but no
no if your engine breaks they can't
avoid the warranty because you stuck the
thing on your windshield
just avoid the warranty on the car now
look up the it's like the Magnuson Marsh
Warranty Act or something don't break
your car nobody's ever had a car broken
I think the worst thing that happened
we've had a few fuses blown and I think
the worst thing that happened was a
camera ECU uh the camera broke uh and we
actually covered it because it was due
to a miswiring in our harness and I
think that happened to one person
so the worst thing that ever happened to
anyone
uh was 900 of damage and we covered it
uh and then people are blown fuses which
two bucks bro
um so yeah if this thing like breaks
your car in normal usage a we're very
interested in figuring it out and B if
it was actually normal usage we'll cover
it
um again we've had that happen to one
person it was our mistake and we paid
for it
Partnerships would be easy with some
Vision please tell me more about this
please tell me more about how you think
this actually is going to happen
uh does comma warranty cover the car no
again
if if like your your tire breaks bro
like no
um
but you know like I said it's not gonna
break your car
uh these things are very uh robust to
that uh
yeah I mean you know what don't take my
word for it look online
um it's all electrical it's not a
mechanical mod so it's it's talking over
the can bus and it's getting power
um
can you send back your broken 3D print
for warranty did you break it or did it
break in the course of normal you is if
it broke in the case of normal use it'll
get a new one
um if you broke it no buy one
um we'll open power stack eventually use
tiny car what do you mean eventually it
started using tiny grad six months ago
uh and like not even a like we ripped
out smpe for the main model it's all in
tiny right now
how does this guy keep coming back
remove
all right we're gonna do like five more
minutes of stream
um
I get low IPC what's IPC I don't know
what that means
inner process communication
can you get drunk yeah but don't drive a
car
um
it's never it literally it's never
broken a car like how would that even
like happen look at a car and then look
at the the
um have I tested FSD beta FSD is you can
read there's a lot more comparisons
online that go into a lot more depth
than I'm gonna go into and I've only
tried FSD beta a few times
um but the big difference is kind of how
chill they are right like FSD is like a
I'm driving now whereas open Pilots like
uh bro I'm helping you out all right our
slogans make driving challenge
do I still drive a Kia
um
my car is actually not supported by open
power very sadly
um but I'm probably gonna sell it and
get a new one that is
uh is comma rev G
pre-production or production Hardware
that's production Hardware
uh dirty tested in a comparison it's a
fair comparison
say like I think some people prefer one
and some people prefer the other some
people will tell you actually I do find
that most of the sentiment I read says
they prefer open pilot to FSD but I'm
probably looking at more mild sentiment
um no I do not I actually have a
Rolls-Royce Ghost uh
open dealership packages would be dope
any dealerships welcome to offer it
right
um
looking for a designer yeah guys we're
trying to hire a designer Alex I shield
for this a whole bunch I really think
the interview is that they should just
put some mocks or put something up on
our GitHub all right like if you want a
job here you know how to get one
you know I I hope the whole world moves
to this and the tiny corpse entirely
like this I really hope the whole world
just says like
you know I don't want your resume I
don't want to do an interview why would
I do this stuff like this is what we
make
can you help
right because that's the question that's
the fundamental question that's being
asked at a job
um
and then for things where it's like okay
like our research Stack's not open
source so like we have a programming
challenge there we were just saying in
the meeting this morning saying every
single person who still works at comma
either did well on the calibration
challenge which is a like a difficult
computer vision challenge or
has contributed to open pilot before
they started working here
and if you're not either of those
why would I hire you
like you don't work out well you get
fired
and that's just historically what's
happened
uh injection molding designer we have a
hardware team
um who by the way
uh
the hardware team got hired through the
same process
everyone on the hardware team actually
the three people on the hardware Team
all either were external contributors or
do well on the challenge despite doing
Hardware so
um how's the comma body I mean you saw
the common body watch the beginning of
the Stream
are we considered languages other than
python let me show you something
how much of open pilot do you think is
written in Python
all right this is some myth that open
pilot is written in Python
uh uh
well it's more python than I thought but
it's uh 35 C plus plus
so all the stuff that's fast is already
written in
designer UI ux designer brand
designer I don't know what any of this
stuff means you see open pilot I want it
to look better and communicate better
whatever can do that
all right like you saw the lane change
thing it looks terrible comes up with a
bar that blocks the bottom of the screen
that says bro you're making Lane change
like don't do that you know
um
we'll detect speed humps and
experimental mode I will sure
do you put a box on a speed hump in your
head like I just I can't even like
tolerate this anymore you know
who still thinks like that man
um
well navigation pilot ever be capable
photo automatic Lane changes yes
uh yes in certain supported cars right
like you know it's a spectrum of how
well supported the car is but if you
have a car if you have both a comma
three and a car like the the ev6 which
has good Corner Radars yeah sure I think
I can I think I think we can make Lane
changes more reliable than you
cone guy needs his job no he doesn't man
no he doesn't
why is experimental mode so slow we're
working on it it
there's challenges there's challenges in
the simulator and I can talk about why
there's a bias toward going slower and
going faster but
like this might not even be true but
like one theory is that the simulator
only has a certain amount of
longitudinal range and obviously slow
things are less likely to fall out of
the simulation range so the RL keeps it
I don't know if that's being corrected
for it but we're moving to third
Paradigm models we're using simulators
it's all going to be better
um
the common body is going to do that
common body is going to make ice no
we're going to open comma coffee you
guys hear about common coffee we're
doing a mall store too we're gonna open
a coffee shop at our office and the
robots are just going to serve you
coffee and it's just going to print
money because we got robot labor man
um and then the software Engineers of
course get paid a lot more to make the
robots good but someday man someday
three common bodies are gonna get inside
an Acura ILX and they're going to drive
it to Phoenix they're going to open a
donut shop and they're going to be
bringing me back a box of cash every
month and like George why are they
bringing you back a box of cash why
don't they just send them money
wirelessly and I don't trust that put
the money in the box and drive it to me
that's right
um
to have a partner from the community
what do you use a product fix whatever
you think the problem is
you know what I mean like do you have
something you don't like about it fix it
I suggested one thing but you can do
something else
thank you thank you thank you I
appreciate that
um
you can't use native campus you can't
use native cams you can't access them
installation is already hard enough
um too many people start with forks hey
man it's your product
from whatever software you want on it
that's the beauty of it
um
motorbikes no
nobody has died nobody has gotten
seriously injured with a comma part of
the reason is because the cars are very
safe
um
not support motorbikes
can you get a job validating video data
are you a computer
um
none of boats
uh live stream yeah I want to do that I
want to do that from connect I think
that's with the body stuff
I'm not trying to like measure the band
it's like make driving chill like you
gotta get it or you don't
um
look we've done no marketing you don't
understand like like advertising that's
great what devices am I going to sell I
don't have enough little boxes to sell
but this year we 2x the number of little
boxes we're selling and now it's too
many little boxes the factory can't keep
up so we've got to expand the factory
and get oil Boxes by the way we're also
hiring ahead of production
um I'm so shocked at how bad all the
applicants are for this role I want
somebody who knows every part in a cell
phone I don't think this is that hard
I'm not gonna like ask you I'm not gonna
like troll you and ask you about like
some like random you know transistor but
I'm gonna ask you basically like what's
in a cell phone and who makes it and I
don't know how people don't just like
know this
um do common devices upload video clips
to us yes is there an option to turn it
off yes it's open source software it's
not a toggle you got to go in and edit
it
um it doesn't upload the front camera
has a toggle the main camera uploads by
default but again it's open source you
can turn it off
Nick is still at comma yes who makes
Snapdragon CPUs that's a good question
um don't give away my interview
questions
um what is the new product it is an
extended warranty it is a two-year
warranty for your comma three it is four
hundred dollars
um look
it's not for everybody but I asked about
this on Discord and I said what are
people willing to pay
and like at 200 it doesn't make economic
sense for me uh at 400 it does so we did
it it didn't make sense for a long time
and again it's not because the failure
rate's high it's because of the
increased liability on the company right
like that's a liability what I'm selling
right
um so we have to say are we going to
support the comma 3 for two more years
and the answer is yeah so there you go
right like it's going to be still under
warranty and then so we're gonna
basically it's a commitment to kind of
support it for two years
warranty tangible I know what that means
um but yeah you want to look at it let's
take another look at the warranty
comicare extended warranty
come move into iot I don't know what iot
means uh no no it's one more year for
200. so it's a total of two years of
coverage
uh that would be committing to support
it for three years and we're not willing
to do that we are willing to commit to
support it for two more years
we don't send we don't send things to
YouTubers Linus Tech tips reached out
you know it must sound into a device you
can buy one if you don't want to pay for
it you can return it within 30 days if
you want to review it give me an honest
you know we're not like I'm not here to
like partner and do like that kind of
like scummy like oh well we partnered
with this this this YouTuber and uh not
doing that I just think it's gross man
like I like what Tesla does they're just
like yo man buy a Tesla and talk about
it cool bye come and talk about it
um
one more year yes one more year
uh
uh this video is sponsored by Common AI
I know they're actually not paying me
bro I swear they're not paying me
my salary right now is zero My
Equity has been zero for a long time
so you know Do It For the Love of the
Game
I do it because I'm a shareholder I'm
sorry
would love to comment three buy one
today
um
oh they know about comma but like again
I think they were expecting something
different from us
like I think that they reach out to
these consumer electronics companies
they're like oh Linus Tech tips this is
our big break and I'm like bro like
review it if you want buy one if you
want talk about it I mean we appreciate
it but like
don't do it if you don't want right
uh can you buy our shares not really
some are very few are available on the
second Market uh
the only real way to get comma shares is
to come work here
uh one year warranty is actually uh
mandated a one-year manufacturer
warranty is actually a mandated at least
in California
um 50 discount on parts now
if you break your if you damage your
screen those screens cost me way too
much money I'd like the new screen is a
bit cheaper but they still cost me way
too much money I'm very upset at how
much I'm spending on screens because I
know how much phone people are spending
on screens and it's a lot less
I'm never going public why would I want
to be owned by Bankers you're not going
public right there is no public
is the oligarchy and the oligarchy is
the banks right so if you want to be
owned by Bankers then you can go public
if you want to be owned by people then
you know you stay private you'll stand
in your PR all right how is this guy how
come there's no ban there's no
man maybe I'll add them as a moderator
you know we'll do a full 180.
um can't buy it through the Toyota TSK
buy uh we have votes for that
all right two more minutes
don't ban you law band
and
two more minutes any last questions uh
how hard is buying a comma for a brand
new car and fingerprinting it for a
software engineer very easy
it should just work uh if you're saying
your car is not supported it depends if
the model is not supported but the brand
is it's probably an hour of work if the
Brand's not supported well I think we
kind of support all the brands now but
if the Brand's not supported it's a lot
of work
what older Toyota do I recommend a 2021
corolla's fire a tss2 Corolla it's great
car I mean look it's a great car for
comma I personally hate the Toyotas but
that's just me
um I just think they're like it's loud
you know buy account a Sonata if you
want a nice car
I got my parents by Henderson
what music are you listening to hyper
pop
um
how long will it be before comic reviews
on all types of vehicles it already can
it's Tesla supported not really
it's like saying like do you want anyone
Android and iOS
um
you should make it possible to search
cars by type I mean how many minivans
are there the new website's the best one
we've done
um I bought any new cars no we're kind
of done buying new cars we're gonna
improve the ones we have
um by the way can you believe that GM
canceled the bolt like they finally got
a car that some people are buying and
they're like you know what we should do
let's cancel it yeah that's brilliant
I've loved your executive thinking let's
go make Partnerships
um
why don't I advocate for stopping AI
why would I want to do that I love AI
um stopping progress
why would you want to stop progress
aren't you a progressive I'm gonna
progress of progress
only conservative
GM dissolved after they cancel The Vault
oh with a V oh we're really going back
now
um
hiring remote people comma does not hire
a remote uh tiny Corps does uh comma has
a strict no remote policy we have a
beautiful office here uh no remote uh
but tiny Corp will hire you remotely but
you got to contribute
um
you missed the product announcement the
product is a comma care one-year
extended warranty for your comma three
it's four hundred dollars and this is
the fine print and you can read it
um people always ask George but what's
going to happen when this is out of
warranty you should really offer a
two-year warranty now we do you can buy
it it's 400 but that's so much money
cheaper than a comma 3 was originally
comma threes originally were 19.99 now
comment threes are 14.99 so for the kids
in the back what's 14.99 plus 400 that's
right 18.99 you still save a hundred
dollars and get a two-year warranty what
uh deal
foreign
have sales going up yeah sales have 2X
and it's the price decrease sales have
2X it's hard to disambiguate but between
the Taco Bell video and the price
decrease we are 2x in the number of our
devices are selling
are there any oems that wanted to
integrate it oems have reached out again
like by a phone call we sell phone calls
if any oems would like to talk to us we
sell phone calls for a thousand dollars
um hotel conference rate discount codes
I don't know Alex can we do that
can we like promise like 20 people are
going to buy something and get a
discount on the hotel it sounds like a
good deal
thoughts on app Tara uh you know I'll
see let's see what they have when they
ship uh you know I also I'm curious how
safe that car is uh but if they ship
something and it's safe good for them
I mean again it's probably safe for the
motorcycle but
that is one of my concerns about that
car it's not like you know is it as safe
as a Toyota RAV4 yeah Prius yeah
you know I've seen Priuses hit concrete
barriers that uh at 70 miles an hour and
everyone walks away
um
I never seen a motorcycle do that
uh but no look at Tara look apptare is
an example of if companies want to use
open pilot they're welcome to just use
it it's open source software it is our
trademark you don't have to acknowledge
that's our trademark if you want to use
open PAD if you want to Fork open pilot
MIT license is super permissive
um
uh your comment thanks for Banning my
comma three your comma three will be
banned from our network uh only if you
mess with safety code
if you mess with safety code if you mess
with driver monitoring or you try to
raise torque limits uh you'll be banned
right like again I'm not here to stop
you from doing this stuff what I am here
to say is I don't want anything to do
with you or some guy was asking in
Discord like can I disable the seat belt
check and will I get banned yeah you'll
get banned right don't mess with the
safety
again getting banned doesn't mean that
the police come to your house right it's
just it's just saying that we don't want
to associate with you or if you want to
mess with safety if you don't mess with
safety by all means look tons of people
out there uh go out and run uh and run
Forks we're very supportive of forks
um Forks the change you can change a lot
of stuff without touching the safety
uh no actually we don't send no but some
someone did uh did try a return scam on
us and we sent a pi to their house we
took the device back and I'm filing a
police report later today do not steal
from comma
uh no like I'm very serious about this
he's going to be super upset when the
police come to his house but do not
steal from me like you're stealing from
me
um what does it mean to be in the
network it means that your device can
connect to our servers and use our
backends and all that stuff
uh I will only go after them if they
associate themselves with comma no if
you you can run whatever code you want
you bought the device for me I don't
care I'll just ban it from the server
right I'm not going to go after you I
will go after you if you buy a device
from us and try to do like a fraudulent
chargeback oh hell yeah I'll go after
you
um
all right
thank you for watching today's stream
the stream has been brought to you by
the comicare extended warranty comma
care extended warranty only 400
uh you can buy it for either a new comma
3 or a common three purchased in the
last year obviously for obvious reasons
I hope you can figure out I can't sell
you an extended warranty on something
that's not in warranty
um also sponsored by automatic plant
watering systems bought from Amazon
it Waters the plants for you so you
don't have to
um
I said it wasn't sponsored well I
probably lied
uh thank you thank you all for watching
today's stream
um
it's not weed
what was the new product the new product
is a warranty that's why product was in
quotes
uh
how I tried home assistant I don't know
what that is
all right guys thank you for watching
the Stream
have a good day
buy a warranty come to Comic-Con and if
you want to come work here
it's pretty easy
uh can you buy a warranty even if you
don't own a comment you can but it's a
donation
thank you
bye-bye